neil patrick harris shares his
excitement behind his new netflix series
uncoupled and how the romantic comedy is
something everyone can relate to i'm
just a big fan of the show i mean
netflix has been a super supporter of
gay content
of giving us the opportunity to tell a
story that is both unique and super
recognizable and relatable it's a
breakup show it's a breakup comedy by
darren starr so you have sex in the city
vibes but you have sort of a gut punch
of emotion which he didn't really wasn't
really able to accomplish so much on sex
in the city
and so i was worried that people would
only be able to watch this if they were
a gay man of a certain age
i thought is this show too niche do you
know what i mean
but in point of fact i think everyone's
gone through a breakup or everyone's
terrified of going through of being
broken up with
and this show is
a comedic take
on that idea that also allows you to
like get swept away and care about these
characters so i was really pleased to be
a part of it after 17 years my boyfriend
told me he was leaving me
and he kept saying oh i'm officially out
of the fan club he also reveals what
it's like to have been with his husband
david berka for 18 years
wow david and i started dating and we
never stopped
so an interesting way it's all i've
known
like i didn't come out until later i
didn't really
date a bunch of random people
i wasn't around during the times of
grinder and and swipe left to wipe right
so
i fell head over head over heels for
this dude and
and he was into me and we started
living together relatively quickly and
now we have 11 year old kids and we're
still going strong so i'm just i don't
know that's my singular story i don't
know anything different and i'm i'm
super happy i'm very grateful and in
true nil fashion he goes on to explain
his new tattoo and the magical
inspiration behind it
i always wanted a second tattoo i was
filming a doctor who special in london
and i knew that tattoo was going to be a
top hat
and a magical sort of
classic one i wanted it to be very
detailed
and i figured the brits would know how
to do a top hat better than the
americans
so i had it done there and this amazing
frenchman named thomas did it
and it only took like four hours i'm
glad it was done
[Music]
you